all right how did I miss that that's all
good let's get an F chord where were we
shout out to the comments our segment
okay check us out so we have the story
from American military news they say
California City to use night Chinese
night-vision drones banned by US Army to
enforce coronavirus lockdown and this
photo is actually really cool but it
reminds me of like all of these
dystopian futuristic I don't know
fantasy worlds books cartoons whatever
we're like the drones fly around and
like stop and like citizen you're
outside of your home you must go home
immediately and now that's literally
what's happening I mean whoa okay not
literally but the drones are actually
tracking people to see if they're
breaking curfew
yeah they look at your phone right
that's crazy that's what I heard yeah
man put on put on all black mm-hmm get
your bow and arrow gotta be quiet that's
why
and then you lurk around I'm just
kidding symmetry don't do that when the
drone comes it doesn't even know you're
there you got a really good aim though
well well a small target we did just
watch the movie the hunt and in it they
say don't shoot the drone because now
they know you're there
yes that's true so this is I'm not super
unless you're actually not anywhere
close to your home cuz then you can
shoot it and then dip back because then
they'll go there look in for the person
who shot down a drone you know it's you
know it's really yeah what's really
scary about this is how awesome it
sounds to be like a resistance member
yeah you're like running around and
you're like a drone for the
establishment get out I'm imagining like
John Connor in the future you know
fighting the drones this is what a lot
of these like activist people who wear
all black think they're doing when they
go around like bashing old women over
the head and like not doing no but I
feel like we're getting dangerously
close to that world where you know we're
gonna be in it so this is in Chula Vista
California police so I do want to point
out man they really laid on the framing
of this article Chula Vista where is
that so it's in California like it's
isn't Chula Vista like is that LA area
is it oh I don't know
I never never heard about that but they
call it a Chinese drone it's like yes
that's true
it's DJI it's the drones everybody flies
yeah it's like 77% of the seriously the
drone market is DJI I was actually just
randomly reading an article about that
an hour ago it's it's true though I mean
it is Chinese made and but mine I
thought they were banned because they
were Chinese made really well so I so
here's here's what I think it says it's
banned by the US Army I would have
assumed it had something to do with the
night vision there's something it's like
because the army a drone is a drone like
what they're not banned so no but I fly
with a night-vision drone be Chinese
they don't know because it was Chinese
yeah there's most of them are so our old
drones banned
theirs they're not all Chinese so it's
like you gotta you gotta buy American I
mean I mean best buy like a month ago
and they had they had all sorts of DJI
drones yeah yeah the Mavic I got like
well here's here's the big fear is that
this is a few years ago there was fears
that China was putting Wi-Fi and
bluetooth hidden inside like toasters
and coffee makers for real and that way
whoa wait no for real they were or for
real this is what the rumor was it's
it's hard to call it a room it's a
little bit more than a rumor but around
there you know it's like either not a
confirmatory either rumors not worlds
because I'll put it this way well
Roasters a rumor would be like your
buddy being like you hear this crazy
story okay a conspiracy theory would be
like a person screeching online being
like they're putting all the toasters in
the wind and then the water purifiers
okay so this is this one no no this one
was the US Army saying out of credible
intelligence reports that China has been
doing this we are now gonna stop using
this but there was a pushback saying
it's not true
some people think it was just an effort
to get the u.s. to spend money on US
made products like it's an excuse to not
buy Chinese but there was a fear that if
you buy this like I'll put it this way
would you if you went to war with
somebody and you were using their tech
right press the button your drones and
fought at the sky or just you they can
like tap into the fee exactly like hmm
what are they looking at oh they're
following that citizen haha we've got
them looking at their own citizens dude
think about computers yeah they're all
made over in China and so how much you
want to bet all of our computers like
that are made in China
they've got some kind of backdoor put in
them why not I don't want to believe
that
but probably true I can see that it
could be possible but there's some
Chinese dude right now who's like
watching you watch porn and he's like
senator eating popcorn in like a China
Chinese authoritarian firewall police
like that makes me uncomfortable I mean
well I'll tell you what it gets better
that not only is there a Chinese guy
doing it but there's an NSA guy doing it
they're both sitting there watching just
chill and the NSA guy he like he like
DMS the Chinese guy and he's like yo can
you believe what he's watching freaking
he's like yeah man I swear I mean that'd
actually be cool that's why we're having
a plague no no look it but but if the
NSA guys and the Chinese people were
friends and we were gonna go to war you
know some benefits there but but but
anyway I don't know exactly why it was
banned they just say we have not
traditionally mounted speakers to our
drones but if we need to cover a large
area to get an announcement out or there
were a crowd somewhere that we needed to
disperse we could do it without getting
police officers involved they're
literally talking about drones that are
gonna talk to you and be like citizen
return to your home like wow so they
have speaker systems on them that's what
he just said yeah they're gonna be
outfitted with night vision and
loudspeakers that's crazy so here's what
we say the US officials warned against
using Chinese drones domestically so I
think it's just really about it being
Chinese made yeah Chula Vista may also
use its drones to relay messages to the
city's homeless who may have less access
to information about specific
coronavirus orders Wow that's kind of
interesting it's both really cool and
horrifying at the same time the drone
light comes down and it's like homeless
citizen there is a quarantine and like
go to this location you know turns the
woman Jeffrey yeah yeah yeah it's your
friend Matt what up get and then the
homeless by the way you got to go home
the homeless guys like I have a question
and then the drone terms of well one
second turns back yo did you watch the
new episode of Westworld yeah I saw
tiger king dude you see it and then like
two drones come down and the two drones
are talking to each other it's like cops
parked opposite ways on the street but
but no it is simultaneously really cool
to like it to live in this nightmare
dystopia yeah as I'm saying it's like
horrifying at the same time yeah I'm not
really scared of drones other than like
the blades could hurt somebody if some
morons flying it so they got to figure
out that yeah these things to me
dangerous man
so that I love how to use the victim
defense we need to tell them we actually
have a resources resources for them they
are vulnerable right now Sally said it
might be impractical or unsafe for
officers to be put in those areas right
so again whales just don't want to get
sick no no right right we're not gonna
go over there we're just gonna send
drones everywhere we can't risk it
we're sending the drones because we care
about you by by the way put these cuffs
on protection we're just trying to keep
you safe mm-hmm
yeah that's the big fear right do we
just blindly trust the government what
how do we know that this thing's
actually gonna end when it's gonna end
we don't or if it's even real yeah no I
mean never let a good crisis go to waste
yes that's what they say it would be
absurd in my opinion to think that China
and the US have teamed up like secretly
well granters like five or six states
that banned abortions now because they
were like oh well it's you know we gotta
just Italy yeah fight everyone's going
for a gun shops getting that moment
knows - so like wow but we so we see the
gunshots gun shops get shut down we also
see the inverse like everybody's taking
their opportunity to just feel like
now's my chance ones afraid let's take
advantage of this yeah gross so they say
China reportedly introduced large-scale
drone enforcement during its coronavirus
lockdown efforts and citizens said
drones would relay messages to tell
people to remain in certain areas or
call out pedestrians not wearing face
masks what we saw in China and we're
probably gonna see around the world is
using drones with cameras and
loudspeakers to fly around to see if
people are gathering where they
shouldn't be and telling them to go home
he said it's a little Orwellian but this
could save lives I love the but but
security yeah that's a big but yeah so
there's one thing I've kind of been
harping on for a bit we've we've like
the First Amendment's been just crushed
completely yeah it's like what that
you're not allowed to go out wearing a
mask didn't the government say we don't
we don't need to wear masks kind of kind
of or what well so early on there was
that the main narrative was that it's
not as effective for people to wear wear
and if everyone goes out to buy masks
then medical professionals won't get
them okay the irresponsible
irresponsible media then turned that
they it was corrupted into don't wear a
mask yes the telephone through the media
right so masks obviously work but
there's a problem with its it's better
if everyone's wearing a mask okay it's
much better if medical professionals
have priority access to them yeah but
all across the country there are no
masks there I oh there it is now well
they're finding some Everywhere's
finding some somewhere but nobody has
masks how are you supposed to go out at
all and get food or even look for masks
well no oh you don't have a mask get in
your home they're just now just now for
you say you get masks right so this is
there is no masks so this is the main
issue I take with it is that it's always
about the lie justifying their goal yeah
like it was obvious that masks did help
to a certain degree
mm-hmm I you know the point I tried
making early on and and I probably
deserve some criticism for this too
because what I was saying is you
shouldn't buy masks because for one
medical professionals need axes them to
access to them first
no to the when the people wear masks and
protective gear they do it in a really
odd achill way like that we have to put
them on a specific Auld yeah there's a
word for putting on taking it taking it
donning and doffing yes there you go
yeah so what we were seeing a lot of was
people who are buying them and having no
idea to use them yeah and then getting
filthy and then just getting sick anyway
yeah so or with full beards with a mat
right over it's like nice good job but I
guess now that they feel confident
they're gonna get the masks they need or
something they're starting to say maybe
everyone should wear masks well all
these companies are making them too I
got a few people that I know that are
just crank and masks out yeah yeah my
sister is making a bunch of masks really
like how like sewing just yeah she's
cool got a silence awesome just making
them yeah couple kids to worry about too
right right yeah based for him they
found that the n95 masks like the ones
of the actual filters yeah really really
good but even like I think I guess Trump
said something like put a scarf on
because it still helps I mean if they
say the molecule
is tiny but it still rides in the
moisture and air so it would make sense
that having something to filter it
you're lessening the chances of getting
it yeah so what's what's the harm and
without something now we got a bunch of
companies that have switched to making
masks like the my pillow guy yeah yeah
he got a bunch of flak everyone was
yelling at him but New Balance
understand why they why would you give
him flak for that he bought he brought
thought into it yeah he was like saying
you know now's the time to come to
family read the Bible and stuff like
that but like who cares
yeah he's writing something good why you
care so much people yeah you know I mean
that's the libertarian in me like I
don't have to believe what he's
believing I don't have to like like take
that tart and be like wait a minute you
don't believe what I believe so now I'm
gonna be mad at you it's like come on
man
I almost imagine it like imagine Michael
and I was like here you go buddy here's
a mask my mask is the best math you
sweat out of his hand and you're like
get your religious mask out of my [ __ ]
I'd rather got sick that mask is
religious I don't want it what Oh
if a communist gave me a mask and had a
sickle and a hammer on it was an n95 I'd
be like thank you sir I'm not I'm not
worried about showing up to a rally of
like anti communist like if you give me
a functioning mask and you wanna put a
little thing on it I'm just like I'll
take it if I need it a picture of some
family guys scene where he goes to take
the mask and puts it on the mask is like
whoa whoa whoa Oh sir Sir sir have you
read the Bible today Oh
oh sorry no and he's like no no no I'm
out here any walks out the door you can
give me a social justice fist rainbow
flag man cannot be alive and I do not
care you can give me a mask with a
picture of the good Lord and the cross
won't be like thank you for the mask you
know it's funny the my pillow
commercials on the TV there we go I did
you know there there was all these
different people like digging dirt up on
this guy now and just like to tell like
oh well he's not the perfect person it's
like nobody's the perfect person nobody
and sure he he did some stuff in his you
know the crack addict yeah there's
whatever and like you know that his
companies got into some tax issue or
some stupid thing it's like but he's
paying it off and it's like why he's
he's doing us a like help he's doing a
service
that's that's good and and they called
it a thing it was CNN called it a PR
stunt not really but I'm but it's like
everything everything everything is in
some sense yeah is it a PR stunt when
Facebook gave masks they're like we
bought all these masks and weren't given
the hospitals that wasn't a PR stunt
yeah well I mean okay so it's the same
thing as like saying it's religious it's
like you can take that to heart as what
you think it is but in the end it still
helped like this whole thing with Russia
like Trump said Trump accepted all this
stuff from Russia like the help the big
Plane full of stuff and everyone's like
oh man it makes us look so weak and
Russia's superiority over us since like
or we also really need that help right
now because China makes all our stuff
and hasn't given us anything
so Trump's like yeah it's good it's good
that they're giving us this stuff cuz we
need it what do you think about that
well I agree I mean no matter what he
does gonna be bad like here's medical
relief supplies and they're like that
proves it Trump is working for Russia
yes any Putin is giving his
second-in-command important would you
rather get the stuff from China like
honest question huh
would you rather turn the ships around
that we've actually paid for the masks
they're like now we're gonna keep him
this actually reminds me of a religious
joke you guys want to hear it okay I
don't know if you call it a joke but
it's uh something that I heard a lot
when I was younger so there is a man in
his home and a storm hits all of a
sudden the waters start rising and
there's a flood someone runs to his door
or as the floodwaters are rising and
he's in the news what's happening he
prays to God saying please save me don't
let the flood you know kill me and then
someone knocks on his door and says
we're getting everyone out of here quick
hop in the truck before the waters get
when he says no no no the good Lord will
save me and they're like buddy don't be
crazy get in the car we're leaving the
floods coming and he's like nope I know
the Lord will save me so then as the
water start rising and he climbs at the
second floor he starts praying again
please don't let me die the flood is now
too high when all of a sudden is a knock
on the window on a second floor cuz the
flood so high and there's a boat and the
guy in the boats i quick get in the boat
we gotta get out of here he says no the
Lord will save me and so the guys like
are you nuts
and he goes I refused the Lord will save
me and the guy takes off in the boat so
then the water starts rising he climbs
onto the roof and now the water is
getting close with ankles the floods
come in and he's like help me Lord when
a helicopter comes and they throw a rope
down and they're like quick climb up and
he goes no the Lord will save me and
then they were like are you nuts once
again they take off the floodwaters rise
and the man dies he goes to heaven when
he gets there he gets to meet God and he
goes I don't understand
I was religious my whole life and I
begged you for helping you let me die
and he goes I sent a truck a boat in a
helicopter you wouldn't take any one of
them yeah yeah so I that would work the
the assumption that you can't take help
from someone because you expected to be
perfect is what I get from that too yeah
along with the you know God works in
mysterious ways
what do you think he would have accepted
like a big hand that came right this guy
up on little man I think it's a good
joke because it works religiously and
not yeah like to accept the help from
people who offer it yeah it's never
gonna be exactly what you expect you
know what I mean yeah help and
opportunities they come along you gotta
take it exactly what that saying god
helps those who help themselves well you
know God works in mysterious ways right
sure but shall we shall we move on to
the snitch in your neighbor portion of
the day so yes Niagara this week I don't
know this website is is like for is it
for Niagara in New York or something yes
what is it the news guarded no it's not
oh good see now I got me wondering every
time you get you get addicted you're
like someone has vetted this even though
they are pretty they're they're biased
but I they're all right you know but
this is a Niagara this week I can only
assume it's you know the the Niagara era
Niagara Falls and that area is full it's
Canada and New York ish okay no man's
land but they have a very importantly a
very important philosophical question
for all of us should I snitch on my
neighbor for not properly self isolating
during the corona virus pandemic you
should just scream at that this is silly
what would you do what would I do
I mean I've seen I've look out the
window every day I'm like ah look at the
weather oh look there's my neighbor
walking you know with his wife it's like
yeah
they're not self isolating but they're
not sick are they know their feet away
from other people no not each other
oh but they're a couple what am I gonna
do like hey there's a couple that's my
neighbor and there they're walking
together and it's like people have done
that that's ridiculous that was I wasn't
the Ebers cutoff for only like in New
York didn't he say I forget who said it
but it's like you're only allowed to
uber if you're with your significant
other
what didn't you say that I thought
nothing you mentioned like three weeks
or month ago maybe is a long time yeah
it was a while like it was like right
when it started hitting New York you
know you know you mentioned the other
day that it was March 97th yes every I
am seeing everybody say the same thing
yeah yeah on Twitter everyone's like
yeah it's been three years in March
April Fool's it's still March yeah I
think it was uh was Kyle kolinsky who
said I'm glad the year of March has
finally come to exactly what happened
those nuts well I mean honestly a lot of
people died you know it's it's from the
end of February until the end of March
four thousand people so yeah I don't
want to go outside I'd rather stay home
but does that mean you should snitch on
your neighbors well apparently one woman
thinks so in this viral video
woman flips out on people not isolating
from coronavirus in absurd viral video
when was that from two days March 31st
so yesterday Wow look at how many views
that is that ton of views we watch it
let's watch almost 3:00 she's not
wearing a mask
she got within six feet of them what the
heck he was spitting all over him when
you sneak out of quarantine and Karen
catches you that's good so what is this
no I get it is that that's the story
these people are weirdos but they're
there they're doing it to this out New
Zealand Police website for snitching on
people breaking coronavirus lockdown
crashes due to poppy
clarity oh wow he can't neither can i
well listen I got a question though if
you're in your car aren't you isolated
isn't that an isolated place what's
wrong with driving around what if you
got to go to the doctor or yeah what if
it was what if you're driving to the
store to get food get her out of food
you're driving in a bottle yeah they
said that we can leave four essential
items essential shaman's it's like she
saw a kid and was like he was probably
cruising like with his friend like yeah
we're going to the store this sucks
we got the short straw oh there's Karen
she's a psycho
there was another video I don't know did
you know there's another video that went
viral of a preacher and he started
filming this woman screaming that he
they shouldn't be out and she just
literally screams like we top of her
lungs and it's incredible yeah and my
first thought was like she said near
yelling this guy and mom I'm gonna ask
him quite like what are you doing out
yeah cuz if you want to argue that
you're going to the store know you're
standing and arguing with some guy and
you're supposed to be like isolating
yeah I saw her hit the window which is
physically touching like if she had the
sickness now that kid has a sickness on
his car yeah you had the sickness she
didn't have to necessarily get it from
him but definitely it would have been
the other way around I think so let's
let's what's up what's up with this New
Zealand people love sinchon on each
other what the heck reclaimed them
reading them reclaim the net says one
constant that's come with the spread of
the corona virus has been the
proliferation of digital tools that are
slowly encroaching on people's civil
liberties and recent comments when the
New Zealand police revealed the alarming
rate that people are willingly adopting
these tools to snitch on their fellow
citizens according to the New Zealand
Police a new website that was set up for
citizens to snitch on people who violate
the country's coronavirus lockdown rules
was so popular that it crashed due to
the volume of complaints it was
receiving under New Zealand's current
lockdown rules residents have been
ordered to stay at home keep contact to
a bare minimum and stay two metres apart
when they leave when they do leave their
homes Police Commissioner Mike Bush told
reporters we've had 4200 reports of
people believing others weren't
complying odd she's Bush added it shows
how determined Kiwis are that everyone
complies with us the rollout of
this online snitching portal in New
Zealand is one of several others that
has been introduced across the globe the
US government has also reportedly
started using phone location data to
track the movements of its citizens amid
the corona virus outbreak another change
that's been criticized for its impact on
civil liberties they're gonna mention
that the digital rights group the
Electronic Frontier Foundation wrote the
government has not shown that the new
dragnet location surveillance powers
would significantly help to contain
kovat 19 and added that fear of
surveillance chills and deters free
speech and Association you know I'd be
very much more on board with a lot of
these organizations like like EF F if
they didn't go full-on intersectional
dawg dogma religious you know weird oh
yeah so you know I'll agree with them to
the extent like you're right they
shouldn't be tracking our phone data
yeah but you know outside of that I
digress thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do
the show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you